morning everybody it is Monday you are
very welcome to join us here on the
breakfast show on Sky big breaking news
for you that will impact almost all of
us we're hearing that Liz truss is
preparing to scrap plans to remove the
45p top rate of income tax for the
highest Earnest Downing Street has faced
a bitter backlash against the plans led
by the former cabinet minister Michael
Gove who said that the Prime Minister
had no mandate for the change Grant
shapes who will speak to shortly the
ex-transport secretary agreeing with him
saying handing big giveaways to people
who need them at least is no way forward
joining us now is our political editor
Beth Rigby um hi Beth you're up at
conference Tory Party Conference in
Birmingham tell us more
morning k
um yeah a huge uh story is emerging this
morning which has huge implications for
the government and as you said the
country uh having insisted yesterday uh
that she would stand firm the Prime
Minister and her Chancellor are expected
to decide to announce that they are not
proceeding with that decision to abolish
the top rate of tax that's the 45 Pence
tax rate it affects one percent of
earners those earning 150 000 pounds a
year they were going to scrap it from
April
2023 next year and as I understand it
they will now not proceed with that
policy it's a massive U-turn even
yesterday as I said the Prime Minister
said we have to stay the course but the
Rebellion not just from uh back benches
but I think also from within government
has obviously proved too great
okay why have they done this in a great
scheme of things it's not a lot of money
but they weren't reading the room were
they
that's exactly right Kate it wasn't a
lot of money it saved two billion uh in
uh tax Council cost 2 billion rather and
that was in a 45 billion package but uh
it was not consulted upon in uh cabinet
Liz truss told the BBC that yesterday uh
and quasi quatang took the decision one
cabinet minister said to me uh it wasn't
right that he hadn't told the cabinet he
should have discussed it more like
widely given uh that it was such a
contentious policy and the political
toxicity if you like of cutting the top
rate of tax for the richest people or
richest earner should I say in the
country amid a cost of living crisis has
prompted a huge uh rebellion and we've
seen it with Michael Gove yesterday uh
publicly coming out saying it should be
opposed and Grant shot so I think uh
you're going to be speaking to soon Kay
saying in a article in the times this
morning that it was an unforced error
harming the government's economic
credibility now those calls are not just
happening outside government they're
happening inside to uh Liz trust
obviously wants to reset the dial she
wants to get rid of this story this
problem this Rebellion it was going to
dominate uh the Party Conference and
they are now I think preparing to
announce that they will not proceed it's
the first massive U-turn of a government
and of a prime minister that has
insisted all along uh that the political
Optics of policies is not her concern
she wants to do what's right she's told
me that she's prepared to be unpopular
it's clearly a step too far and I think
it speaks to the fact that underneath
the smooth exterior of this conference
that the conservatives are trying to
portray that there are a lot of choppy
waters on underneath and this is a prime
minister he's now having to make
decisions she might not want to in order
to try and take down the political
temperature okay so she threw the uh
Chancellor under the bus yesterday uh is
the writing on the wall for him now
I think that the chancellor has had a
really difficult start because of this
policy I've asked a lot of people
in the party about that there's no doubt
that they would agree that he has been
embattled but I think the thing that uh
consulters say to me as well is that the
project if you like of this radical
change to economic policy is really
being driven by Liz truss and
quasi-quartan in unison with the other
two in their economic quad as they call
it which is Simon Clark the leveling up
secretary and Jacob Reese smog the
business secretary and quite frankly I
think Liz trust at the moment is quite
politically vulnerable because she
doesn't have a ground swell as support
in the back benches and some very very
Senior People such as Grant shaps and
Michael bever making it difficult for
her so however she is feeling about her
Chancellor or tensions she might decide
now is not the time I should also say
though that I have pressed uh those
around Liz truss about this sense of
tension between her and her Chancellor
and on the issue of the 45 Pence rate of
tax I was told yesterday that the Prime
Minister fully backed uh quasi-quarters
decision uh to do it even though today
they are reversing so in terms of the
outward perception number 10 is
certainly trying to present it as a
union united front uh between the charts
and the Prime Minister but this is
obviously going to be hugely politically
difficult for quasi-part Tang on the day
that he is delivering his economic
speech on the economy of speech on the
economy in which he was about to say
this afternoon we have to stay the
course and he will kick off the day we
expect with a reversal on that decision
to abolish the top rate of tax the 45
Pence rate and what does that mean for
conference uh Beth as a result you made
the um point that it was originally
going to be dominating conference that
it was 45 paid out at 40p now I'm
guessing it's going to dominate
conference that the lady was seeing on
the screen has already done a u-turn
I think there's two ways to look at this
um
this was going to dominate conference
even last night um when I was talking
uh to to ministers uh to government
figures are they saying well look we can
delay the vote we don't have to vote on
this measure until March next year on
The the abolition of the the rate so we
can buy some time and we can park the
issue but clearly uh the building of the
rebellion led by Michael Gove and now
Grant shouts this morning there has been
a political calculation that if they
don't reverse on this policy they can't
get past it at this conference and I I
read it and let's see what they say we
haven't heard anything yet it's just
what I understand is going to happen it
might be that they hope that they can uh
reverse this decision today get it over
and done with and then reset and get on
uh with the conference because obviously
politically number 10 and number 11 have
realized that with this route going on
through conference it will completely
Dominate and drown out everything else
by I think you're right that the
transfer and the Prime Minister haven't
been so publicly Resolute in saying we
are not for turning we'll have a lot of
explaining to do today as to why they
are going to change the policy why today
Beth what's happened
well as I said I think there was a big
um there was a big Brewing rebellion and
it was framing uh this whole conference
in a very negative way of a new prime
minister in but a few weeks come into a
conference where I mean the times was
reporting that 14 I hadn't plotted them
all up at 14 MPS were publicly saying
you cannot do this at this point in time
when there's a cost of living crisis and
the other way you can look at this is
that Liz truss is listening to her back
benches that she will adapt if she sees
that something is not politically viable
so that's one way you could interpret
what they are going to do
but it is no doubt a very difficult
thing to explain when a prime minister
has insisted for the past week that they
will not reverse the policy the
political Rebellion has clearly become
too great and they want to do a U-turn
and hopefully for them quickly move on
yeah but I mean she was Resolute
yesterday on that that she wasn't going
to do that uterine wasn't she Beth and
she was throwing her as I said her
Chancellor under the bus yesterday
morning and now it looks as though she's
on the cusp of changing her mind we
believe an announcement around about 7
30 something like that probably tying in
with the market
um is it down to somebody like Michael
Gove who you mentioned who um is always
or he may not be um you know in in the
top echelons of government at the moment
but he's always somebody that is going
to influence at the conservative party
look okay I think I think the thing is
is that if we step back on what's going
on kind of beneath the surface in the
conservative party
let's trusts only one in the first round
of votes from MPS 50 votes she then went
on to win win the leadership but she
never won publicly the majority
supported the Parliamentary party and
that tells us that she yes has a very
supportive cabinet and she has a big
chunk of the party that ideologically
agree with her in terms of trying to
Turbo but charge the economy in the way
that she is doing but at the same time
if she cannot take her party with her
and is the conservative infighting
continues all through her first
conference when she's already 33 points
down in one poll and other polls all put
in uh the labor leader and high double
digits and even into 20 points plus if
she cannot take her party then she is in
seriously deep trouble and I think that
there has been a political calculation
here that they do not want this now over
the abolition of the 45 Pence rate which
as you said is a small element of the
entire package of that mini budget to
completely swamp uh this conference I
mean one senior conservative said to me
last night it simply was a mistake the
bankers bonus decision and the top rate
of tax were two relatively small policy
announcements in a massive package but
they have completely distorted the way
in which this budget was received and
the prospect of cutting tax rates for
the highest earners in society when
people are struggling with double digits
inflation the prospects of rising
mortgage rates those high energy bills
even though there is government support
they are still running High uh not being
able to lift public set to play with
inflation and even a discussion on
whether or not benefits will be uplifted
by earnings rather inflation rather than
inflation it is really making tourism
extremely anxious it's anxious for their
constituents anxious about the prospects
of re-election and actually for prime
minister who said she had would plow on
overnight clearly she has listened and
taken soundings and realized that she
needs to u-turn on this policy I imagine
they will try and keep it very contained
and quickly move on let's see if they
can uh I I just want to keep you for
another couple of minutes Beth I know
you've got other things to do phone
calls to make but let's just listen
quickly to what the Prime Minister said
just yesterday
I do stand by the package we announced
and I stand by the by the fact that we
announced it quickly because we had to
act but I do accept we should have laid
the ground better I do accept that you
accept and I I have learned from that I
have learned from that and I will make
sure that in future we do a better job
of laying the ground did you discuss
great with your whole cabinet
no
no we didn't it was a decision that um
the chancellor made
yesterday morning less than 24 hours ago
Beth she said that she was standing by
her package now it looks as though she's
on the cusp of uh completely doing a
U-turn what are the Optics not only for
the chancellor but also for Liz Tross
honestly I have to say it's not just
yesterday morning when she was talking
to the BBC about this policy it was as
late as last night when I was talking to
senior government figures they were
insisting as late as last night before I
did a report into the 10 o'clock news
that they weren't going to scrap this
policy what they were going to do
instead was delay the finance bill
that's when you put in all the measures
through the measures of the budget
through Parliament delay most of it
until next year to buy themselves uh
more time but I think a couple of things
have happened in the past 24 hours I
think that Jake Berry uh talking to
Sophie Ridge yesterday on her Sunday
show saying that uh those that rebelled
would be stripped of the witch so they
would be punished by the party I think
that that really agitated uh back
benches and I think they realized that
this was a battle with the Parliamentary
party that whether they did it in
November or December or March next year
they couldn't win it and that it was
going to completely overshadow this
trust's conference what they will be
hoping to do is if they can do this
today and because if you like takes the
heat of it because it's economy day and
it's his big speech that Liz trust will
be able to reset this conference and
move on because quite frankly the
conference has started with a massive
route over the top rate of tax which
isn't going to go away they've now
clocked that and realized that it is
better just to kill off this policy that
was not really survivable anyway on the
back benches and try and move on but it
goes against everything that the Prime
Minister has said ever since she was
elected I am prepared to be unpopular is
what she said to me and she insisted
that she was not going to reverse any of
these policies as little as 24 hours a
day go another busy day ahead for you
Beth I'll let you get on thanks so much
indeed thanks a lot
I've given an eye on the markets I don't
think they're quite sure what to make of
it it was 111 when I woke up this
morning it's gone up to 113 down to 112
back up to 113 again against the dollar
while they figure out
um how they feel about the expected
announcement at 7 30 that the 45p rate
of interest of tax I should say for the
very highest earners was going to be
scrapped and replaced by the 40p tax
um that is now going to be scrapped in
itself a 45p highest rate of income tax
was part of a growth plan that was put
forward by quasiquartang the new
Chancellor freshly into his job is mini
Budget on the 23rd of September it
already looks as though he is about to
announce a U-turn Tamara is in
Birmingham for us how's this going to go
down with the party Faith well tomorrow
good morning
good morning K yes party faithful and
some of them not so faithful I think
this news of an imminent I expect will
hear it very shortly from the government
u-turn on this 45 P tax rate Liz truss's
decision to abolish that rate paid by
people earning over 150 000 pounds is
really going to Electrify at this
conference I think we came here with the
mood very edgy you had a lot of
conservative MPS even those who've not
spoken publicly some of whom are even
ministers in Liz truss's government
knowing they'd made a big misstep not
necessarily on the policy although many
of them dislike that the way it had been
communicated to the public the way that
other people were brought in because Liz
trust herself admitted the chancellor
had made the decision alone they could
all see the polls with huge leads for
the labor party and a lot of discussion
about how the conservatives had the
wrong priorities the likes of Michael
Gove and Grant chaps going public saying
You must spread the pain evenly this
sends entirely the wrong message I think
the news that Liz truss appears to have
made a very late night decision last
night to change course on this is going
to please some in the conservative party
a lot of MPS who had criticized it at
party members some of whom I spoke to
yesterday who wondered whether it was
the right call but it's also going to
upset others there were ministers in Liz
truss's cabinet who had taken heart from
her saying look we know it's not popular
but she thinks it will help to generate
growth and therefore it's worth sticking
with because an election is still two
years away and there's still time to
make the argument I think the fact that
Liz truss has u-turned very quickly and
in politics if you're not going to win
votes you do need to U-turn quickly but
I think to some in her cabinet it will
appear that Liz truss has given in very
easily and they will see that as not a
very good sign for a brand new prime
minister less than a month into the job
that with an 80 seat majority that she's
inherited at the first sign of trouble
she is going to U-turn so I think look
if you're going to change course as I
was speaking to a senior conservative in
the last few days it's better to do so
quickly and try to move on try to
salvage what has undoubtedly been a lot
of damage caused by this policy but as a
sign of her Authority I think for many
conservatives it's an ominous one
um yeah so I suppose
um we were hearing we're going to hear
from the chancellor later he was going
to say his policies were the right ones
and that he was going to press on
obviously it looks as though that is
going to change so others will now be
looking at their policies on I don't
know corporation tax and the reverse on
the National Insurance increase as well
which you know let's face it would have
cost an awful lot more money than this
45 down to 40p tax return return
is going to embolden a lot of MPS who
are critical of list trust and as Beth
was saying there a lot of MPS are
critical of Liz truss she didn't win the
rounds in Parliament of the leadership
contest and I think we're going to get
another budget at the end of November
when this um you know the chancellor is
going to set out how some of these
measures are going to be paid for and if
those measures proved to be unpopular
then I think those MPS who have have
been critical of the 45p rate might
think well if we get together and start
criticizing them maybe she'll reverse
course on those two so I think very
difficult decision for a prime minister
to u-turn on a policy that she has
personally supported she says drives her
aim of securing economic growth she had
suggested yesterday in that interview
that it was more a failure of how the
policy was communicated than the policy
itself but for Liz trust was set herself
up as someone who doesn't change course
who's prepared to be unpopular who's
prepared to take the tough decisions
that Britain needs as she often said
during the contest this is this is a
this is a serious blow and I think
um while those around her have clearly
said that there was no chance of this
vote passing I was very struck yesterday
talking to a senior minister in her
government who simply said to me 45p is
not going to happen
clearly she thought the arithmetic
wasn't there but the votes on this were
not going to be held until March so she
decided not to try and make the
arguments for it over the next few
months but simply to try and say okay I
got it wrong and try to move on on some
of her other policies but she has been
stung by the fact that having announced
an absolutely huge measure to freeze
People's Energy bills over the winter
months which is going to cost around 150
billion pounds she has found herself in
a political crisis over a measure which
only costs around 2 billion pounds who's
going to take the wrap for it
well that's the interesting question Kay
and I think we'll be watching very
closely to see what the chancellor says
when this is announced we expect to be
within the next half hour or so and
whether allies of the chancellor later
suggest that he was unhappy about the
move I mean quasi-quarting had intended
to say today he's giving his big speech
to the conference this afternoon we will
stay the course we I'm confident he was
planning to say that we have the right
plan the whole day is now going to be
overshadowed by this U-turn and the
feeling that they got it wrong Liz truss
put the ball very firmly in the
Chancellor's Court saying he made that
decision he wanted like Nigel Lawson in
the 1980s to simplify the tax system he
said it made no sense he said that it
actually brought in less tax when you
had that 45p rate than when it was at
40p conservatives were saying that for
much of the new labor years you didn't
have a 45 P radio attacks they were
making all these arguments now they're
going to have to Simply say people
didn't come with us we didn't bring the
public or conservative MPS with us and
therefore we can't do it and I expect
there'll be a lot of frustration in the
Chancellor's camp today and from
conservative MPS who are unhappy about
this policy I think there will be Knives
Out for quasi-karting you're already
hearing suggestions that if Liz trust is
to try and Ride This Out maybe she won't
be able to keep him as her Chancellor
her key Ally yeah we're talking about
Michael Gove referred to Michael Gove
they're also Grant shaps has got
thoughts on that but um as far as
Michael Gove is concerned
um there he is um at conference
listening looking significantly Slimmer
than we've seen I saw some pictures of
him jogging in the papers this morning
um he's as I said to Beth he's not in
the high restaurants of government at
the moment but he's still a very
powerful politician isn't he yesterday
morning we heard from the Prime Minister
she was not for turning even at 10
o'clock last night when Beth was
speaking to us on News at 10 she was not
for turning has this man got anything to
do with the decision that we're
expecting in the next three minutes
and okay I think Michael Gove
articulated what others across the party
were feeling they did not U-turn because
he toured the TV studios criticizing
their policy um you know as annoying as
that would have been for his trust and
her team they will have taken soundings
from across the party whether MPS were
going to vote for it many had told them
that they simply wouldn't MPS in
marginal seats because of course they're
thinking of the next election in two
years time whether they were prepared to
support this policy and also when you
look at who is criticizing it you've got
to look at how organized they are I
think figures like Grant chaps who help
to organize Boris Johnson's leadership
bid in 2019 he's the sort of figure who
can really get people organized you've
got others who supported Wishy sunak who
are former Chief whips people who are
good at doing the numbers so they will
have looked at who their opponents were
and exactly how many people they had
behind them in making the decision and
to change course last night but the
discontent went pretty wide and pretty
deep within the conservative party even
people who had backed Liz trust for the
leadership said that they were concerned
about the message it sent in what
everyone knows are going to be tough
times over the next couple of years to
be cutting taxes for people on the very
very highest earnings
indeed so
um we were told that quite a few back
punches we're not going to go to
Conservative Party Conference because
they were particularly unhappy with the
mini budget and the impact that it's
having on their own constituents
obviously it's very important to her
that's what that Ventures think
um do you think that they will welcome
this
so Rishi senac of course who lost the
leadership contest is not here and some
of his key supporters are not here
either
um I would say that it's quite common
for Tory MPS who are not in government
roles not to attend the Party Conference
it's a bit different to the labor
conference there aren't lots of votes
that they need to take part in for
example but you did see a lot of
conservative MPS saying look I'm not
going to bother attending but it's
interesting that
um in terms of leading this Rebellion
Michael Gove and Grant shafts do not
need to be here but they both are here
not doing any official events on the
stage but just touring the TV studios
touring what are called Fringe events
which are events not at the official
conference but happening in the margins
of it to criticize the government's
policies but as I say they reflect far
wider discontent including among
ministers when I arrived yesterday okay
I ran into a few senior conservatives
none of whom have spoken publicly
criticizing Liz truss but sort of a
shell-shocked air around them that you
know you've had loads of opinion polls
giving big leads to the labor party
you've had conservatives saying look
this reverses all the work we've done
over the last few years appear appealing
to voters on Lower incomes that
everything you know you had
um Rachel Wolfe who wrote Boris
Johnson's 2019 Manifesto essentially
saying this goes against everything that
we were trying to do and the all the
indications were pretty bad and while
Liz truss will upset right Wingers in
her party including in the cabinet who
feel that she should have faced down the
rebels and tried to make the arguments
over the next few months until all this
will be voted on in March clearly the
Prime Minister and her team just felt
that they had no chance of this getting
through Parliament that the next few
months would just be dominated by the
idea of a tax cut for Millionaires and
it was better if you're going to change
course to just do it quickly and try to
pick up the pieces but I think talking
to insiders in government a few days ago
they were very much safe
tomorrow stand by for just a second just
want to share this tweet with our
viewers um that is just coming our way
it's a little bit small so I'll read it
for you
um from supporting British businesses to
lowering the tax burden for the lowest
paid our growth plan sets out a new
approach to build a more prosperous
economy however it is clear that the
abolition of the 45p tax rate has become
a distraction from our overriding
mission to tackle the challenges facing
our country as a result I'm announcing
we are not proceeding with the abolition
of the 45p tax rate we get it and we
have listened this will allow us to
focus on delivering the major parts of
our growth package and then he goes on
to talk about the growth package but
basically we get it we have listened is
what he's saying so it's been left to
the chancellor to do the U-turn is he
toast do you think
tomorrow yes just reading this this from
just reading this from the chancellor
um complete complete reverse various I
mean it had been some thought that maybe
they would try to delay it but the
abolition of the 45p rate has become a
distraction from our overriding mission
so they've listened they know that they
have not got the support for it and
while Liz trust and quasi-quarting we'll
try to say that perhaps they didn't do
the groundwork they didn't make the
arguments with Tory MPS in advance the
fact that this was a signature measure
from the chancellor that they both said
this would help to generate more tax to
get the economy growing to meet all the
promises that they had made over the
last few weeks about how they would make
difficult decisions to get the economy
in a better place I think this is not a
good sign for the Chancellor's Authority
and I think
while they will leave this conference
feeling that they've headed off
a massive defeat in Parliament headed
off or tried to head off the impression
that they were giving a tax cut to the
very richest while refusing to commit to
for example lifting benefits by the rate
of inflation I think the chancellor will
leave this conference also with his
authority very much weakened and fit the
feeling among Liz truss's many critics
in the party that if they can do it this
time perhaps they can do it again
yeah but the fact that it's a tweet and
it's from the chancellor as opposed to
the Prime Minister who less than 24
hours ago was saying yeah we're on
course
um I don't mind if I'm not popular but
I'm going to crack on and then overnight
there's been a reverse ferret and it's
been left to this man to tweet about it
absolutely and I think we will
be over the next few hours trying to get
a sense of exactly how that decision
unfolded and whether it was indeed a
joint decision but certainly Liz truss
put the blame for that policy said the
policy was the chancellors gave him the
responsibility for it and it is now
fallen to quasi-quarten to say we get it
and we have listened the tempees don't
support it
couldn't really be a more difficult
start to a new government just a month
in to have one of their signature
economic policies dismantled by
opposition within their own party and
we're already starting to see those
who'd criticize the policy publicly
welcoming this U-turn okay just looking
at some of the reaction now now coming
in we
um Grant chaps who will be speaking to
us at any minute now has said that it
was it was the right decision conserved
is what lower taxes but let's show our
energy price cap and other policies that
are on the side of consumers because so
many MPS and even ministers in Liz
truss's government felt that having
spent 150 billion pounds on freezing
People's Energy bills to try and make
sure the winter was not as difficult as
it may well as it could have been they
were getting absolutely no credit for it
having announced a policy which for many
just sent all the wrong signals about
about her intentions giving a tax cut to
the very richest while um in the view of
many sort of failing to protect the very
poorest and you can labor are going to
be a jubilant about this I've just had a
message from a senior at labor source
close to kirst armor who said the Tories
have destroyed their economic
credibility and undermined Trust in the
UK as a result so this will be known now
as the conference at which a huge U-turn
was carried out and I don't think
there'll be much of a hearing for
anything else yeah just looking at
annalize Dodds actually who was tweeting
yesterday
um and suggestions that the government
had potentially thought about going even
further many will be sickened by media
reports of champagne cropping Tory
donors encouraging the chancellor to
press ahead with further tax cuts for
billionaires so they're worth
considering even more tax according to
tax cuts According to some newspapers
over the weekend
well there's some very toxic stories
over the weekend Kay we know that after
that Friday's mini budget
um this Chancellor had gone on Sunday
news programs saying that there may be
more tax cuts and that was given as a
factor which had helped to move the
markets on the Monday had seen the pound
at full to that level because the
chancellor had suggested that having
announced all these unfunded tax cuts he
may even go further you then had over
the weekend a story confirmed yesterday
by the Tory party chairman Jake Berry
that the chancellor had been drinking
champagne with City people including
hedge fund managers and the suggestion
denied by the Chancellor's team that
they had been they've been egging him on
in some of those policies and what
obviously looks very bad so look the
U-turn is now there it appears to have
been decided very late last night and
it's the chancellor who has had to
announce it after the Prime Minister
said that it was his policy and he
hadn't consulted the cabinet on it
before announcing it on that Friday so
quasi-quarten's big drive to simplify
the tax system which he said would
kick-start economic growth bring in even
more money is already fallen by the
wayside and you just got to wonder
whether a Liz trust his critics will see
this and be sort of sharpening their
knives for the next time she does
something a bit unpopular yeah indeed so
let's bring in Ian King should we our
business presenter of course um Ian I
think the market I'm right and saying
the markets open at eight
um yes what might they do
well that's right Kay we've actually uh
already seen a reaction though in terms
of the markets because uh Sterling uh
obviously is a 20 foreign exchange is a
24-hour market and Sterling has reacted
you can see it on the screen there it's
actually a paranda uh two-thirds of one
percent right now against the US dollar
so there's been a modest soda reaction I
mean the truth of the matter is that
fiscally speaking this isn't really one
of those policies that moves the needle
I mean it was only going to cost
something like 2 billion pounds a year
and in fact in the next financial year
it was actually going to raise some 625
million pounds because of uh the changes
of uh people's timing of their bonuses a
lot of people would wait for the
scrapping of the additional rate so it
doesn't really move the needle in terms
of the public finances obviously uh it's
the Optics that are far more important
but it's I think it's pretty unfortunate
for the government to put it mildly
because obviously they're still going to
get all of the opprobrium uh the
perception that they're a party for the
rich without actually getting the
benefits of this move because there were
actually very very sound reasons for for
scrapping this uh additional rate it was
uh off after all it was only bringing uh
the top rate of income tax uh back to
where it was for all but the last six
weeks of the labor government under Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown so uh as I say
fiscally speaking it doesn't really move
the needle I'm surprised actually uh in
some ways that there hasn't been more of
a response because it kind of doesn't
show the the government up in a
particularly good light the fact that
this this was a pretty totemic policy
that they've uh suddenly reversed on it
doesn't really uh send a good signal to
the markets because now people wonder
what else might they uh Backtrack on
but the markets don't deal in Emotion do
they
I mean markets are are dispassionate and
unsentimental and I think what this
measure tells you is that uh the first
whiff of Cannon far uh from some of
their rebellious bat benches the
government backs down so uh there was a
in terms of what time is talking about
uh with his uh fiscal statement it was
all about making the UK economy more
competitive uh this unabashed focus on
growth and all of a sudden uh it turns
out that they're not very keen on the
some aspects of driving growth and it
doesn't go down terribly well with their
bat benches indeed so um for now thanks
very much Ian thank you um let's bring
in Grant shops uh should we previously
transport secretary
um has been very vocal uh about this um
cut in tax from 45p to 40p with us now
uh from Conservative Party Conference at
Birmingham of course hello to you you
must be pleased
a morning Kate yeah look the right thing
to do uh this I mean it just couldn't it
just doesn't wash I noticed very
strongly as if I needed any evidence
when I was knocking on doors in my well
and Hatfield constituency on Saturday
morning the people were saying look I'm
about to take on another shift at work
because I'm so worried about mortgage
rates and I understand that rates are
going up because inflation was high
because of Putin's Invasion but what
they didn't understand is why the
government would be borrowing money in
order to fund uh a uh a tax reduction
for people who are better off and in
doing so spooking the markets and
potentially making those mortgage rates
even higher in the process so the policy
didn't stack up and it didn't make sense
and it's absolutely right and proper and
I'm very pleased it's been done quickly
that the government's u-turned on this
and I I strongly welcome it this morning
um why do you think she's changed her
mind what do you think they've changed
their mind yesterday morning she was
saying the lady's not for turning
well I I as I said to the Prime Minister
and and to the chancellor it couldn't
have got through Parliament uh it was
just no there's no mathematical way that
uh MPS were going to go and vote for
this you didn't have to knock on many
doors to realize how deeply unpopular uh
it would have been and that was a Pity
because it was a big distraction from
the much much bigger funds going into uh
capping the energy prices uh which is a
multi-billion pound uh cap doing really
great things so it was actually
distracting from all the really good
work that the government was doing
sometimes when you get these things
wrong as the government did in this case
uh it's best just to acknowledge that
and move on and that's why reading quasi
uh katang's the the Chancellor's
statement this morning where he just
says I get it I'm pleased to see he's
absolutely right you know this could not
have gone through and uh and and you
know there's no way that you can simply
say well we're going to push it through
anyway that's not happens it works I get
that Mr Shepstone I suppose my question
is what's happened between yesterday
morning and today
um that for that I'm afraid you'd have
to be asking the the chancellor the
Prime Minister what I do know is it must
have become increasingly obvious to them
as I went out myself and others to say
uh soundings are you will not get this
through Parliament soundings from the
public are this is deeply unpopular and
it's distracting from the good work as I
said on things like energy and other
changes that they're making that this
could not possibly go through so I think
shall we say reality sunk in
uh we get it we've listened from the
chancellor why do you think I'm
interested to know your thoughts as to
why the chancellor is tweeting rather
than hearing it from the leader of the
country
um again that will be there uh that
that'll be for them to to say I I mean I
don't think that the Prime Minister
would possibly be able to go all the way
through conference without referencing
it uh so I'm sure when she gives
interviews or when she makes her speech
she'll have to make reference to this as
I say I welcome what they've done it was
the wrong move at the wrong time and
sent the wrong signals and it was also
spooking the markets of course so I
think that for all of those reasons
um you know credit where credit's due uh
they've changed that I want to see
things move on I want to see the Prime
Minister be successful I want to see a
conservative government who if nothing
else should always be there to protect
the nation's purse to look after money
make sure it's sound uh so you know this
is a very very important moment that
they're showing their Ash you're going
to do that as a government and I hope
also they'll pay a little bit more
attention as the Prime Minister said to
the communications as well because it
does matter it matters hugely people
need to understand and what the
government's doing and why the
government's doing it and then a little
bit more energy needs to be put into
that as well okay let me put it more
bluntly is he toast
no I don't think so and actually we saw
him for example the 2012 budget long
time ago now it was called the Omni
shambles budget it was a George Osborne
budget that went terribly wrong but what
he did at the same time was to reverse
some of the measures that were causing
the problem in that budget and as we saw
we actually went on to win the next
election so I think it's important that
this has been done quickly I think it's
important that the chancellor has
acknowledged that he got it wrong and I
think he says in his statement this
morning you know we get it we understand
we you know that was not the best uh
thought through approach they wanted to
do everything at the same time and
sometimes if you try and throw
everything in at the same time it
creates a blockage it was too much and
you know I want to see lower taxes
um I I expect every conservative and
most people in the country would like to
see lower taxes you've got to sequence
these things according to outside
factors including the massive pressure
on household budgets right now we can't
go borrowing money in order to cut one
particular facts at this point in time
yeah I mean I hear what you're saying
about the past attacks and and the like
but he'd already been Chancellor for a
couple of years by then this is his
first budget and he's already already
doing a massive u-turn
yeah but on a budget which actually does
an even more massive amount of things so
that that budget if you think about it
has you know brought in I think the
biggest energy cap in Europe and
certainly the amount we're spending
looks to outclass other European
countries on protecting People's Energy
bills uh that changed to what could be
called a an employment tax that's the
National Insurance change and many other
measures so it's a huge budget anyway
even when you remove this part of it
this part of it was two billion pounds
worth of expenditure so it was not the
biggest part by any means at all but it
was a massive distraction and that's why
it had to go it was actually distracting
from the other good stuff he's doing so
now I you know I think um uh the
chancellor can push on now I hope he uh
does I hope that actually Chancellor and
the Prime Minister think about the way
that they're communicating stuff going
forward it really matters so the markets
to the conservative MPS of course but
mainly to our constituents and to the
country and I think we need to make sure
that going forward in the future that
these things are much better thought
through and they're much better
communicated so yeah so you're saying
that it was communicated badly and badly
thought through
well the Prime Minister herself said it
was communicated badly um I agree with
her uh and clearly you know actually you
might have a desire to do something and
by the way I share their desire I want
lower taxes across the economy but I
also understand that first of all we
have to have the economy moving we have
to make sure that we're protecting
people from these high energy costs as
they're doing and so much else and it
just it speaks to your priorities
doesn't it and so yes of course this is
the wrong moment for it that's why I
said they needed to change it and it
would be a bit churlish if I did not
recognize and appreciate the fact that
it's been changed this morning
um what's going to happen to those
millionaires now that they wanted to
keep happy
well look I mean people who are on these
higher tax rates and by the way it can
include people in all sorts of all walks
of life but I mean I think and this is
what amazes me I haven't spoken to
anybody who was on that 45p bracket who
wasn't saying I don't feel comfortable
about this I don't think this is the
right time for this to happen so I mean
strangely it was a tax cut which wasn't
even pleasing people who were about to
receive or would have received that
reduction in in taxation so it was wrong
on every level it was wrong timing on
every level and if you're going to make
these changes you need to set out the
case first you need to explain to people
and I think by the way there is a very
good case for this why uh we should have
uh lower taxes for example our our
taxations higher at that level than it
is for people who live in Ireland for
example in the Republic so you know
there's a perfectly sensible case to be
made but you've got to go and make that
case first you can't just jump straight
to the solution sometimes and you've got
to do it at the right time when the
economy can afford it as well so you
know they made the right move somewhat
belated but I'm welcoming it
um okay so you've not met anybody who
thought it was um a good idea including
those that were going to benefit from it
does that not just illustrate that this
prime minister's Act of touch
well let's be uh let's give the benefit
of the doubt for for the moment uh the
Prime Minister came in there was of
course the uh the very sad well well
because everyone makes mistakes okay I
mean human nature everything in the
country and they were trumpeting this as
a fantastic opportunity to get the
country moving and you're saying that
nobody that you've spoken to
um thought it was a good idea so who
were they speaking to yeah
now I hear you look and I uh you know I
I didn't support uh this particular uh
prime minister in the leadership but she
did win it and she's now done the right
thing everybody makes mistakes uh let's
see what happens uh next I'm looking for
you know if you like wise decisions well
communicated uh to lead the country and
take it forward I'm prepared to see what
happens uh next but uh uh you know as I
say it'd be a bit chillish this morning
if I didn't recognize a policy that
really Jarred with the public it was
very noticeable on the doorstep it was
the ghost who complained uh has been
resolved and I'm pleased to see uh that
happened this morning and I hope that
that full acknowledgment which I hope is
reflected by the Prime Minister as well
as the chancellor as you mentioned
enables us to to move forward with some
of the other bigger stuff we're doing
like trying to get the economy moving at
a faster rate and like the protection
that we're providing for people on
everyone's energy bills including the
businesses
good to talk to you thanks for bearing
with us much appreciated see you soon
you're welcome
hope so thank you former conservative
whip Steve double with us now um hello
uh your thoughts on this um Vault verse
good morning you are I think it's very
welcome I think it's the right decision
uh as Grant chaps is just saying I think
this uh policy had no chance of actually
getting through Parliament and it was
going to cause a huge distraction from
the many positive things that were in
the mini budget and I think the
government have done the right thing to
now drop this uh cut in the 45p right
where did they get the idea it was a
good idea in the first place
well I think we have a prime minister
who has a very clear uh set of ideas and
and vision for what she wants the
country to be and I think many of us
share that but firstly those changes
have to be made at the right time but
also it's very important she takes the
Parliamentary party with her and having
spent a big chunk of time in the whips
office over the last uh year or so
um you know we we put through under the
previous prime minister a number of very
difficult and challenging uh decisions
but we took time to engage with the
pilot parliamentary party listen to
their concerns answer their questions
and take them with us and I'm afraid the
government did didn't do that on this
occasion and I hope that's one lesson
they will now learn
she said it wasn't her idea it was the
Chancellor's
uh well I I think I think the chancellor
and the Prime Minister quite clear they
share uh their view of of the need to
simplify our tax system I think there's
that's many of us all of us conserve to
share that view but as I said it's about
doing these things at the right time and
in the right way and it's very important
to take the Parliamentary party with you
what's happened do you think between
yesterday morning when she was Resolute
to um 7 25 this morning when the
chancellor had to
um embarrassingly tweet that we get it
and we've listened
I suspect it became very clear that they
were not going to be able to get this
through Parliament I I know that there
was a growing number of uh back benchers
who were saying they wouldn't support
this and I think that the Stark reality
probably hit home that they wouldn't
they would lose a vote on this uh and
therefore they they you know they've
done the right thing by rowing back
but at what stage could they possibly
have thought it was a good idea for tax
cuts for millionaires when people are
struggling to eat and Heat
well I think that's a question that the
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
have to uh answer that's exactly the
point that I was making to the
government and to the whips office that
this was just the wrong time that when
so many uh households are going to face
incredibly difficult months ahead to to
meet their bills for us to be giving a
tax cut to the wealthiest one percent uh
of earners in this country it was just
the wrong uh the wrong decision it sent
the wrong message to the country
um I think the Prime Minister has to
explain why she thought that was the
right thing but as I said I'm just
delighted that they have now listened
and done the right thing does she have
questions to answer this morning
well I think she does
um but clearly she has to answer those
questions I as I said I think the most
important lesson that she needs to learn
from this is that in a parliamentary
democracy you have to take the
Parliamentary party with you you cannot
get you cannot just railroad things
through Parliament if you don't have the
support of the back benches and I hope
that she will reflect and learn from
this that it's very important I think
you know the Parliamentary party has
shown over recent months and years we
can make difficult decisions but that we
have to be listened to and you have to
take us with you and I think that is
probably the most important lesson that
the Prime Minister can learn through all
of this how surprised were you that she
didn't even discuss it with cabinet
uh well I think that you know on on when
it comes to budgets
um There Are Rules around that where you
cannot uh share things but I I think on
something you know I I think most of
what was in the budget she had trailed
through her leadership campaign there
were no big surprises that but this was
literally the proverbial rabbit out of
the hat that uh no one was expecting and
I think that was part of the problem
here with that this was a a decision out
of the blue and clearly as she's
admitted that wasn't uh run past cabinet
before it and I think that's all part of
the the lessons that need to be learned
from this sure I mean one of the
problems that your government is going
to face Mr double is that the allegation
that you are out of touch with normal
people and we see this massive U-turn um
is that going to be enough or do we see
stories that are developing in the
papers over the weekend with allegations
that uh the night of the mini budget the
um the chancellor is going Crossing
champagne with multi-millionaire who've
gone short on the pound and made a
fortune to add to the already massive
fortunes and somebody quoted as
describing him as a useful idiot
well I I think that the government have
done the right thing they've admitted
they got this wrong and they've quickly
reversed it and I think that shows that
we have a prime minister and a
Chancellor that is willing to listen and
willing to change when it is clearly the
right thing to do and as I said I think
that is the important thing here that
that going forward there needs to be
better engagement with the Parliamentary
partying with backbenchers and we need
to work these things we need to
understand far better why these
decisions are being made and the
implications of them before they're just
pushed through and I think that is the
important thing to do questions about
events that the chancellor has attended
I think uh only he can answer I can't
answer those for him
um is he hold on to the water line
uh no I hope not I hope that what this
demonstrates is what I've just said that
he is willing to listen and do the right
thing
um and I think as long as he does that
going forward then there's every uh
reason for him to continue
good to talk to you uh thanks for taking
the time enjoy conference thank you
thank you
joining us now
um who we got next
we've got Johanna with us this is great
news Chief exec at in-house
Communications former conservative party
advisor to Boris Johnson of course when
he became mayor of London he must be
laughing in his conflicts this morning
Joe good morning
good morning Kay
um how do you think you how do you think
what if you were advising them what
would you tell them to do next
uh well I think the communications I
think we're all universally agreed on
have been pretty poor uh and I think the
even overnight actually it's been very
interesting you know only Beth Rigby or
your own political editor and many
others were saying that you know the
government were going to stay the course
they were adamant about keeping the 45p
um policy and actually you know by the
morning that's changed we know that
things have happened overnight there's
obviously been some serious
conversations taking place so I think
there is the fundamental point is
they've listened and that is never a bad
thing but it is not a good look when
you're this early on in your
Administration so I think they're going
to have to tough it out today it's going
to be a difficult day for both Liz truss
and also the chancellor quasi quatang
and he's got you know a day of business
day as they call this on Monday so
there's lots of businesses meeting lots
of government interactions government
ministers are interacting the
conservative party have a big focus on
their business activities that they make
sure that businesses understand what's
going on that's obviously been one of
the big problems since the mini budget
and they're now going to have to make
sure that they get people to understand
what on Earth it is they're trying to do
they you know Liz trust yesterday
admitted she hadn't told her government
what was going to be happening
um and it's very clear that that has not
been the right path and also to have a
bunch of MPS that do not understand
what's going on and also do not support
it is not the way to run a government so
I think it's good that they've listened
but they're going to have to now hold
firm they're going to have some very
difficult conversations some very
difficult interviews and they're going
to have to you know make sure that they
concentrate on showing that they're
listening which I think they have done
which is good but they're going to have
to ride this out now
yeah you said you say that um Joe but I
mean yesterday morning she was saying
um she doesn't care about not being
popular she's there to make difficult
decisions and she was going to stand by
her policies she's tweeted within the
last couple of minutes saying we get it
and we've listened the same words that
we've heard from the chancellor of
course the abolition of the 45 rate has
become a distraction uh from our mission
to get Britain moving our Focus now is
on building a high-growth economy that
funds world-class Public Services boosts
wages and creates opportunities across
the country
um why she changed her mind why she'd
done that Vault fast within 24 hours
well I certainly can't answer that
question because I haven't been in the
room however I think you have been
reporting as have others about how
difficult that policy has been we've
seen the reaction since it was announced
so I think it's inevitable that the
government had to listen I think perhaps
arriving and seeing the reaction
firsthand hearing from her team who are
out and about probably getting lobbied
very hard and hearing you know who was
involved in uh stoking up the the
so-called Rebellion has been reported
but I think fundamentally it's you get
the mood you know when you walk in your
team can get a sense that something
isn't right I've been doing conferences
for over 20 years and you can tell that
the conversations are not going your way
you can tell that people are coming up
to you and they're telling you things
that you're not really perhaps expecting
or your response to the questions it's
not going down very well I don't think
anyone thought that yesterday's
interview was particularly strong from
the prime minister so you know she's got
to now try and help turn this tanker
around and make sure that she can get
her party back on board now showing that
she's listening is certainly a star but
it isn't a great start for a Premiership
when you're trying to show you've got
Authority
but what does it say about a prime
minister and a Chancellor when they're
freshly in office they've got a mini
budget and they think it's a good idea
to cut the top rate of tax for
millionaires when there is a cost of
living crisis what does that say about
them being in touch with the voters
exactly I think that's that's exactly
why we have seen the response that we've
seen and that's exactly why I think the
Prime Minister and the chancellor have
taken the decision they've taken we are
in we're in one of those really
difficult positions Kay where the fact
that they're making a U-turn then
becomes the story and oh it's a sign of
weakness but actually if they weren't
making a U-turn we'd be complaining that
they weren't listening so the government
are in now they've positioned themselves
into a rock and a hard place where they
don't have much Choice other than to
take one or other path which are going
to be uncomfortable I personally think
they're taking the right path now in
terms of reversing that decision and I
think it's going to be welcomed by
people that are here in Birmingham and
across yeah but Joe what does it say
about the bigger picture that they
thought it was a good idea in the first
place
well I I think it was a misjudgment I
don't think there's any other way of
putting it I think it was very clear not
only the actual policy but the failure
to communicate what they were trying to
do which I think has been the bigger
issue there is definitely a mood here
where some people are saying the 45p was
not necessarily the problem the lack of
communication about the whole policy was
the problem I'm not an expert and I'm
not going to say that you know whether I
believe it was right or wrong I didn't
think the Optics of it I didn't
understand why with the cost of living
crisis it was the right approach to take
but you know I know there are people
with bigger brains that perhaps felt it
was right I don't understand the logic
I'm I'm sure some people feel there was
a logic to it it's not something that I
understood so I'm I'm glad that there's
a change coming
um okay it's good to talk to you Joe um
probably see you up at conference thanks
very much for taking the time much
appreciated thank you
so
a couple of things
um to update you on uh both from the
Prime Minister and her chancellor who
have been tweeting this morning lengthy
tweet from the uh Chancellor less so
from the Prime Minister both using the
same wording though that when it comes
to the abolition of the 45p tax rate the
chancellor saying we get it and we have
listened and that's exactly the same
wording that we heard from the Prime
Minister who retweeted her Chancellor
saying we get it and we are listening so
that is from listros this morning there
you go she goes on to talk about the
growth in the economy Etc but both of
them acknowledging that they got it
wrong 24 hours less than 24 hours after
saying that they were absolutely on the
right course and were progressing
forward on that course with this 45 rate
of income tax being cut down to 40
percent which which would have meant
that millionaires would earn an extra 55
000 pounds a year at least they said
that that was the right thing to do to
open up Britain to The Wider World
um less than or when was it 23rd of
September less than three weeks later
they have said we've got it and we have
listened